Tobias Elwood thank you very much Mr
Speaker could I ask the minister to make
a statement on the leaking of top secret
military documents
Minister uh Mr Speaker the unauthorized
disclosure of classified U.S documents
discovered last week was clearly a
concerning development the defense
secretary spoke to his opposite number
in the U.S last week and has been kept
closely informed since he is in
Washington this week for a long plan
briefing to the house Foreign Affairs
committee as well as other bilateral
meetings clearly has been able to
discuss things further with secretary
Lloyd Austin and others whilst there the
U.S Department of Defense and
intelligence Community is currently
conducting its own investigation to
determine the validity of those
documents and the circumstances under
which they were leaked the UK commends
the Swift action taken by U.S law
enforcement to investigate and respond
to the league including the arrest of a
suspect as the Secretary of State the
U.S department for defense and the
French Emily have already said not all
of this information apparently leaked is
accurate colleagues will be frustrated I
know that I am unable to tell them which
bits are inaccurate as these are
sensitive intelligence matters but it is
important nonetheless to stress the need
for caution when reporting what has
apparently been leaked and obviously the
investigation is now a matter for the
U.S legal system
as the refreshed integrated reviews set
out earlier this year the US Remains the
UK's most important Ally and partner the
depth of the UK's relationship with the
US remains an absolutely essential
pillar of our security we remain
committed to supporting Ukraine's armed
forces in response to Russia's illegal
Invasion Ukraine has repeatedly shown us
their determination and resilience in
the face of Russia's barbaric Invasion
and as we have said we are working in
lockstep with allies through forums like
the G7 and NATO and efforts like uk-led
International fund for Ukraine to get
Ukraine the Firepower it needs to
rapidly regain its territory
to buy a Sellwood Mr speaker thank you
for that statement can I begin with a
declaration of Interest which is
pertinent to this subject I am a dual
U.S national Born in the USA and I hold
the U.S passport I have grown up
increasingly appreciating the value and
indeed the importance of the unique and
incredible bond that we have with our
most trusted and valued security Ally
but when a security leak of this
magnitude takes place it should not
prevent the legislative on both sides of
the Atlantic seeking assurances which
the minister is giving today about the
Fallout from the scale of the top secret
information now in the public domain and
indeed the changes that may be
considered to significantly limit such
an event being repeated again so I asked
the minister not to hide behind that
General Venere of secrecy here but to be
frank with the house about the process
Mass data is accumulated from a
multitude of sources this is then
summarized to provide relevant
information analysis of that information
forms the intelligence picture which is
then presented to decision makers that
can then lead to action that might limit
or alter the behavior of an adversary to
close down a threat or indeed inform and
persuade other nations to join our cause
so my I ask the minister I'm pleased to
hear that he and the Secretary of State
are speaking with their counterparts but
does he believe that too many eyes now
have General access to sensitive
intelligence with the pendulum of
sharing files swinging too far after 9
11. is there now too much information
almost by default now classified as top
secret for example if Egypt is intending
to supply missiles to Russia surely the
world arguably should know about this or
if a Russian su-27 jet did deliberately
attempt to fire in missile on an RF
rivet joint over the Black Sea last
September this is an act of war the
details of which surely should be
publicized no hidden away in
intelligence files we certainly must
avoid another Daniel Daniels Ellsberg
situation
Mr Speaker as the world enters a
dangerous chapter and we slide
potentially into another cold war the
parameters in which we share and act
upon pooled intelligence surely must be
overhauled so they are fit for purpose
America absolutely is our closest
security Ally but if a vital aspect of
our relationship requires reviewing or
addressing surely we should have the
confidence to do just that thank you
thank you Mr Speaker as my right
honorable friend notes uh these
apparently leaked documents are in the
public domain but that doesn't change
their classification and thus the degree
to which any UK minister or official can
comment on their content and so I won't
be commenting on them the specifics of
the examples he raised nor any others
over the course of this uq he's
absolutely right in setting out the
process by which information is gathered
assimilated and presented to decision
makers he's absolutely right that
uh the breadth and scale of information
in the data rage is enormous
um and he's absolutely right that one of
the key decisions that any organization
organization with intelligence at its
core has to make is how you allow access
to that information so the relevant
people have it with which to make good
decisions and he asserts that perhaps
too many eyes now have access to that
information
um I think that's a matter for different
departments in different countries to
make as you would imagine Mr Speaker the
mod has looked at our own process this
is a consequence of what's happened last
week and we have to place huge trust in
our vetting processes to assure that
those who routinely have access to
classified information have been risk
managed appropriately and we've even
beyond that within the vetted Workforce
there is a very necessary carbon
mentalization of information so that
only those who need to see things to do
their jobs see them
said what we're learning in the
information age where it is about
getting ahead of The Narrative of the
other side is that actually it is very
useful to be able to think quickly about
the information you have and thus there
is a balance to strike but between being
overly compartmented versus being in a
position where people can be well
informed and quickly make decisions in a
way that meets the speed of relevance in
modern competition I'm suffice to say
and I hope the right honorable gentleman
Mr Speaker and the house will be
reassured that of course the permanent
secretary on seeing what happened in the
dod last week has had a good look at
what's going on inside the mod to make
sure if we have any lessons to learn we
do so
so the Secretary of State John Healy
thank you Mr Speaker the U.S is our
closest security Ally so this is of
serious concern
the intelligence we share bilaterally
and through alliances like NATO and five
eyes is fundamental to our UK National
Security and it's essential that this
continues confidently and confidentially
the secretary
of State for defense is in Washington
we're told apparently to discuss this
breach will he make a statement to
Parliament on his return to confirm the
reassurances he's received on how
British intelligence is handled
the minister is right to say the U.S
agencies are treating this seriously the
Pentagon says it expects findings from
its investigations within 45 days
two years ago
UK classified documents on Challenger 2
tanks were similarly reported leaked to
an online forum for video gaming
War Thunder what action was taken
following this leak
and I have a number of questions which
the minister has not yet answered he's
described the documents as inaccurate to
what extent have they been manipulated
and to what extent have they been used
as disinformation
has this leak put at risk any UK
personnel
and is the mod and how is the mod
mitigating such risks
this is the time the UK should be
accelerating Military Support to Ukraine
so what assessment has the government
made at the impact on this of this leak
on Ukrainian plans for a potential
offensive
Mr Speaker while threats to the UK
continue to rise security breaches have
in fact been getting worse on the
defense secretary's Watch 2 000 people
affected by data breaches in the last
mod annual report a 40 increase on the
number of referrals to the information
commissioner and that was last July how
many mod data breaches have occurred
since and finally why is no Minister
designated responsible for information
security when handling intelligence is
so critical to our national security
uh thank you Mr Speaker firstly I I
thought I was clear in my initial answer
the secretary of state is in Washington
this week for a briefing to the house
Foreign Affairs committee uh which was
uh requested in December scheduled in
January uh it is fortuitous he's there
to discuss these matters in addition but
it would be uh inaccurate to say that he
is there because of what happened last
week the right honorable gentleman asks
about uh previous incidents where the UK
mod uh has uh has been responsible for
leaks every time that it happens and I
agree with him it happened too often but
every time that it happens uh reviews
are put in place lessons are learned
both in terms of the way that
information is handled digitally and
also because this was the case last year
the way that documents are removed from
the building on the former there has
been a wide-ranging and robust uh effort
made to assure the digital security of
documents and to ensure that all users
of secret and above systems are aware of
the way that those systems should
probably be used and how information
should not be even be attempted to be
moved from one system to the other and
on physical documents the Secretary of
State put in place bag searches uh
random bag searches at mod main building
immediately following uh the leak of
hard documents last year and those
searches remain in place now the right
one more gentleman is absolutely right
to observe that some of these documents
since they're apparent leaking have been
apparently manipulated for various myths
and disinformation purposes hence why it
is important not only to qualify that
colleagues should be suspicious of the
original content but should be very
suspicious of different versions that
are in circulation subsequently because
they have been manipulated for various
means
um he is of course right to flag his
concern in which mirrors Our concern for
any Force protection implications from
set leaks such as these that was indeed
our first concern and the chief joint
operations was able to quickly reassure
us that all of those involved in the
protection diplomatic mission in Ukraine
are not compromised in any way by these
leaks nor any involved in the wider
support for Ukraine and The Wider
consulate beyond
the I don't think that there is any
impact on the Ukrainian plans for the
offensive uh in fact as he will have
seen in the reporting of these there has
been a degree of amplification from the
ukrainians around some of the casualty
statistics I make no comments on the
accuracy of the figures that have been
pumped and indeed there was reporting
that those figures have been manipulated
by both sides to tell their story but
I'm pretty confident that ukrainians are
intending to stick to their plan and go
for it on on see how many breaches
that'll support information I have for
me today but our writing
thank you Mr Speaker I don't wish to be
disobliging to my right honorable friend
who succeeded me as chairman of the
defense select committee but I feel it
necessary to ask the minister to clarify
the point Beyond any doubt or confusion
that matters relating to defense
intelligence like matters relating to
the intelligence roles of other
departments do not fall within the Ambit
of the departmental select committees
but should and rightly do fall within
the Ambit of the intelligence and
security committee my right honorable
friend was courteous enough to let me
know that he had been advantage of this
urgent question after it had been
granted had he asked me before applying
I would have advised him first that it
was not within the remit of the defense
select committee to seek information on
the this matter and secondly as The
Minister's replies have indicated that
it would be very unwise particularly at
this early stage to discover the
implications of such a leak in public so
will the minister confirm that in any
future questions and answers about
defense intelligence he will address his
answers to the appropriate committee
which is the intelligence and security
committee that can I just help a little
bit I granted the uku not because
chairman of the committee guys thought
it was appropriate so actually we don't
need to level it in that way minister
Mr speaker thank you very much indeed
because I value both the friendship and
the Council of the current select
committee chair and the previous one and
so I think maybe you've said it all
we're now going to SMP Sports Personnel
in Thompson thank you Mr Speaker I'll be
um equally brief and I think there are
clearly some serious issues here to to
consider and it's very very important
that we avoid speculation particularly
as the as I understand that this case is
obviously subjudice in the US no doubt
our intelligence Community are working
hard to with our partners to review
implications reported to and will be
reported to the ISE I certainly don't
want to be pre-judging anything but just
to Echo the comments of the chair of the
the minister confirm that he will work
work closely with the the ISE to make
sure that we are fully able to consider
any outcomes that come forward from this
investigation
uh Mr Speaker I uh note The Honorable
gentleman's concern and indeed my right
honorable friends the chairman of the
information uh and security select
committee we'll make sure that any
matters that can be exposed to them
relating to this are dancing
Teresa Village
I believe the whole house should welcome
the great seriousness with which this is
being taken by our government and by the
government of the United States as well
and I think it's important for us really
to to acknowledge that mass Leakes of
this kind really are unjustified and
serve only to help the interests of
those terrorist groups and hostile
States who would wish us harm
minister
um Mr Speaker my Hospital friend is
absolutely right these leaks is
unfortunate as they are
um only really benefit one group of
people and those are our competitors and
adversaries in the world who mean us
harm and so whatever the
heroic intentions those responsible for
these leaks may think that they have
they are wrong they risk the safety of
our armed forces and they compromise the
work that we and our allies are doing
around the world to stand up to the
challenge to the rules-based
international order that we so strongly
believe in Kevan Jones
thank the minister for his statement can
I concur with his views about the close
relationship that we rely on actually
the United States but there are five
eyes uh Partners now the intelligence
security committee hasn't yet met to
discuss this uh issue and it is the only
committee plan which we'll be able to
look at the classification of material
which is covered and I think it's right
not to make any preemptive statements
about what uh have been in the Press but
can I ask him if we do decide that we
wish to look at this which is I think
there's a good chance we will that we'll
get full cooperation from not only the
defense intelligence but although
intimidation in terms of pursuing the
rightful questions I think that we can
uniquely ask in the closing environment
which we meet
well Mr Speaker in the interests of um
not only expectation management but
accuracy to the house may I say to the
uh writing one gentleman that I will
ensure that we do all that we are
allowed to do and of course we will make
sure that the committee is service with
whatever is releasable
accepting of course
the the content that has been leaked is
not us content and that might mean that
that's a very difficult thing for us to
do
Sarah
we know that Russia is a master of
propagating diff uh disinformation and
this is an evolving tactic increasingly
used by hostile States so can we get a
minute to give assurances that this
issue is being looked at and considered
in Defense command paper refresh
I certainly can it's a very important
thing that we've learned over the course
of the last year that
um the way in which you own the
narrative and that you counter
disinformation is almost every bit as
important as the physical reality of the
battle on the ground and it's an
important part of our work in the
command paper Refreshments thank you Mr
Speaker the leak in the U.S should and
I'm sure is focusing The Minister's
Minds on the importance of our own
information security so to that end can
I ask him to give an assurance that all
information and data relating to our own
Armed Forces Personnel that is held by
private sector contractors particularly
those that are foreign owned is secure
Melissa well Mr Speaker I would fully
expect it to be
um but perhaps I could take his exact
question away ask the question of the
department and write to him so that we
can both have confidence that my
expectation is well-founded
blue Manchester uh Mr Speaker with
regards to the top secret document leaks
and learning from previous incidents the
minister would know a number of years
ago um the diptels of our brilliant
former ambassador to the United States
were leaked and that had real
ramifications with regards to our
relationship with the United States and
the issue of secret documents being
shared within government departments can
I ask the minister this learning lessons
from that to address the challenges now
what any specific Lessons Learned From
that incident with regards to the
foreign office and the um and how our
brilliant former Ambassador was treated
with regards for doing his job and the
leak of secret documents and the point
raised by the chairman of Defense
committee with regards to who sees these
documents number of individuals seeing
that and restricting that does the
minister have a view on that
um Mr Speaker as the uh Shadow Secretary
of State set out in his own question
there have been occasions where we
reside in a glass house on these matters
and so I'm reluctant to throw stones at
any other department
the rich and forward thank you Mr
Speaker and of course the minister is
right that uh we must be careful around
leaked U.S documents that may turn out
to be misinformation or disinformation
but they do appear to reveal that the UK
rivet joint aircraft was subject to a
near-miss
if the secretary of States had assessed
that the rivet joint aircraft had been
intentionally fired upon would you ever
shared that Ministry of Defense
assessment with the house
well Mr Speaker uh the secretary of
state has uh
briefed the house on that instant I'm
not going to offer any discussion on the
version of events that was put across in
the league
he touched upon before probably the main
short-term worry amongst across both
sides of the house is that this leak
might compromise the spring offensive
and which wanted to Spring offensive
which may recruit the most crucial move
in the effort to repel Putin on that
basis will the Secretary of State
undertake to appear before the ISC as
soon as there's anything substantive to
report
yes well Mr Speaker I think there's two
separate issues there uh what the impact
may or may not be of uh this leak on the
Ukrainian spring offensive and
um Shadow Secretary of State asked me
whether I thought it would have any
consequence on that I don't I think the
ukrainians will proceed with their plan
uh as it is and I have every confidence
that they will be successful the
international efforts to Resource their
plan is extraordinary and the plan is
coming together very well indeed as for
uh whether any matters relating to the
spring offensive and these leaks should
be briefed to the ISC as I said in
response to a previous question the
difficulty will be that this is not our
information to brief nor is it a leak
from the UK mod and so whilst I will I
have undertaken to a number of
colleagues who are on that committee to
ensure that wherever we are able to we
share what we can with that committee
has to be very clear that's not our
information to share nor was the leak
our leak and thus I suspect that we're
rather Limited in what we can say and do
with the committee on this matter
Governor Robinson
uh Mr Speaker can I thank the minister
for his response and recognize that the
Hallmark of the last 12 months have been
Mod's willingness I think to publish
defense intelligence unit reports and to
give decision makers and Parliament
legislators and all those affect the
information that we need to discern
between disinformation and to guard
against false flags and I do welcome the
indication he has given to the chamber
this afternoon that there is a review
underway by the permanent secretary
around processes to ensure that the
retention of information on intelligence
particularly is as it should be within
the department but having shared that
this afternoon can I ask the minister to
undertake to return to the house in some
form through statement or written
ministerial statement on this issue when
the review is complete recognizing of
course that substantively the the detail
contained within that review would be
more appropriate for the intelligence
and security committee I'm very happy to
make that undertaking as we um both
conclude our internal reviews we will
make sure that if there is further
information to off to the house we do so
and similarly I've made a number of
commitments to offer Assurance through
written answers we'll make sure those
written answers are shared by the
library
Toby Perkins thank you Mr Speaker the
arrest of uh uh fairly Junior a 21 year
old national Guardsman in relate to this
begs the question of who has access to
top secret information uh Pentagon
officials say thousands if not tens of
thousands of people would see those kind
of documents Now The Minister's right to
say it's a matter of the Americans who
has access to their documents but in
terms of things that we share with them
that are British information
what reassurances can the minister give
us uh in terms of what we're able to say
about the level of um of seniority with
which information that we share with the
Americans goes on the basis of this very
worrying development many step Mr
Speaker we certainly draw No Boundaries
based on seniority around the
information that is shared bilaterally
UK us or within five eyes or NATO
everywhere else information flows to
where it is needed and sometimes the
analysts that is expert on a particular
piece of Russian capability might be a
relatively Junior non-commissioned
officer but they might be the best in
the world at that area of expertise and
so I think rank is probably not the
right boundary to set but what we are
very careful about and I think the
United States and other five eyes
partners are similarly uh uh clear about
is information goes to where it is
needed not to where it is necessarily
wanted that level of
compartmentalization gives enormous
Assurance leaks like these are
exceptional rather than the norm and I
think it's important that we put this no
matter how grave it appears to be in the
cons text of a vast amount of
information that is shared between the
UK and us and within the five eyes
routinely and that never ever sees
anything other than the eyes for which
it was intended
guthren West
there are clearly issues around the
process of vetting individuals and what
reassurances can the minister give that
he says lessons are being learned but is
there something which rings a bell
around the policing problems we've seen
here in the UK around vetting what can
be done holistically to look at vetting
of individuals who have access to
information held by the state in terms
of
confidential information information
about individuals who have access to the
to Top Secret processes
Mr Speaker I looked anxiously for
reassurance from the policing Minister
but um my sense is that the vetting the
vetting to which uh The Honorable lady
refers with regards to the police is a
background and character check around
their initial employment and is
therefore somewhat different to the
developed vetting process that is used
within government and particularly
within the mod and the security agencies
to assure access to top secret and
compartmented information that process
is an extraordinarily rigorous process
involving
um very in-depth background checks that
go back a number of generations plus
interviews and other
um and other evidence Gathering that
allows us a relatively high level of
assurance about the people to whom who
share information
um the exact process is perhaps not
something that should be set out exactly
in public but it is a process in which I
and other ministerial colleagues have
great confidence
Docker to use Mr Speaker I think a
somewhat overlooked Revelation from
these documents was that the UAE and
Russia were not only cooperating on
evading International sanctions but and
I quote the AP report in mid-January the
FSB officials claimed UAE Security
Services officials and Russia had agreed
to work together against U.S and UK
intelligence agencies according to newly
acquired signals intelligence now
despite this knowledge Mr Speaker the
government continues to facilitate
military security and economic
exchanges authoritarian Gulf States and
encourages them to make massive
investments in infrastructure across
these islands so can I ask the minister
after the Russia report has this
government learned nothing about the
cost of doing businesses with
authoritarian regimes or will they
continue just to be the frog that thinks
it can ride the back of the Scorpion oh
Mr Speaker in a style with which I'm now
familiar the honor of genital comes left
and right flanking and down the center
all at once but at the heart of the
question was uh an invitation to reflect
on some of the content of the leaks and
I assuming very clear I'm not going to
do so
speaker we know that leaks of secret and
top secret military information puts
lives at risk at what point Were
Soldiers on the ground made aware of the
breach and what support has been put in
place practically for them as well as
emotionally for their families at home
well uh Mr Speaker the troops on the
ground those involved in the protection
of the Diplomatic mission in Kiev will
have likely been aware of it as it broke
in the news it is not for them to worry
about their Force protection beyond the
Tactical measures they can take locally
that's a matter for the permanent joint
headquarters and the chief joint
operations was quick to assess what the
implications may be for their Force
protection he concluded that there were
none and the mission can safely continue
and the amazing thing about the men and
women who serve in our nation's uniform
is that their instinct is to carry on
with the mission at hand not necessarily
to worry for their safety we're very
lucky that that's the way that they
approach these things